there was a mishap last time I was on
your show I've heard something about
this yeah a little kerfuffle yeah not on
my part though okay apparently set the
table tell us what happened you were on
the show I was on the show we were
wrapping up a wonderful interview just
amazing it did you you were quite funny
as you always are it was splendid
changed a lot of lives mm-hmm think so
yeah
hello but as I turn to say good night
and we're going out to commercial
Andy extended the hand of friendship
which he got this yeah because you
didn't see it I didn't see it but it
looked too awkward to the home viewer to
the person at home it would appear as if
I hate Victor and I don't I love happy
yeah I love that you're a national
treasure
solid gold your blog says otherwise
couple things you actually did yet there
was a lot of people I mean people have a
lot of time Twitterverse has a lot of
time on their hands let's look at the
moment and see if you think this was
awkward let's relive it and take a look
wrist roll that and here we go
[Applause]
you tease me to hurry up a little bit
Rob looks at Angie like I'm gonna give
it to you and then
[Applause]
I was I'm going here but no I'm over
here Oh anyway I I've heard about this
food Twitterverse and I'm you know evil
a nose so I I wrote I apologize I said
hey and I heard I missed the handshake
I'm so sorry you know no disrespect to
love you and I think we have what he
nicely laid out he escalated let's see
what happene you apologize
right you at least to use the initials
and didn't spell it out which I guess I
appreciate ya don't know what it means
yeah now what's all about this Bob
wiggle yeah do you get that a lot Bob
wiggle unfortunately yes
and that's as good as it gets by the way
I get a lot of hey you're that guy
you're that guy tell me where who you
are tell are you from how do I know you
how do I know hey you ain't got no dick
got a dick I'm always like what are you
told you they're like it got shot off in
21 Jump Street my character gets this
thing yeah so anywhere I go it's a it's
the guy ain't got no dick I'm going to a
men's room I started going to a men's
room they go what are you doing in here
yeah I saw the documentary so it's
unrelenting yes yeah I get a lot of the
you ain't got no yeah yeah so just
that's that's your life is a living how
is it it's yeah it's bad